what's up guys welcome back I think this
episode six of lunch money while Wall
Street's
trying to get rich the rest of us just
trying to get our lunch money right
coming to you every day at noon noon ish
before noon afternoon right at noon
five o'clock whenever we get our [ __ ]
together that's fine I've got the
beautiful plane Tamara Nova with us
today she looks like the female Steve
Jobs with the turtleneck going we are
all good how was your weekend Hey
she had a deal with me so it wasn't so
great all right let's jump into the
first topic today tiger virus so yeah a
tiger at the Bronx Zoo in New York City
that's just a positive for kuben 19 I
know it your question is gonna be so
just go ahead and ask it why why are we
in the simulation like first first let's
release a absolute banger on Netflix 14
days in a row number one on Netflix
Tiger king you hit us with the Caryl
Baskin intro last week and now all of a
sudden we have a tiger at the Bronx Zoo
getting coronavirus wish previously I
think people thought that animals could
get chronic virus right they thought
that but there have been pets that have
tested positive but they don't think
that the pet can like what is it call
spread it to the human okay so there's
my animal to human infection but maybe
humans can infect animals is it a
one-way highway or a two-way Highway
one-way highway what I want to know is
how the hell are the animals getting
tested before the humans an answer for
you so you have an alleged answer go
ahead so like you many people on Twitter
were asking that same question so they
asked the veterinarian at the Bronx Zoo
and he said the Kovach 19 testing that
was performed on the tiger was performed
in a veterinary school lab I couldn't
even say veterinary and is not the same
test as is used for people you cannot
send human samples to the vet lab and
you cannot send animal tests to the
human lab so there is no competition for
testing between these very different
situations allegedly oh I'm gonna say
is that humans or animals Tigers or
animals you're telling me that there's
no difference
they're testing blood right let's move
on Apple man just I'm done I'm not a
conspiracy theorist I'm just trying to
bring up facts here for you guys every
day around noon go ahead Apple masks so
Apple is doing a very cool thing they're
designing and producing face shields for
medical workers they're aiming to
produce 1 million face shields per week
I think they've already done 20 million
maybe no so that check can we have a tio
fact check I'm gonna start using that
action I like this fact check 20 million
medical masks are like the ones that go
around your ears over your mouth no
that's what they got they sourced it
through their supply chain how the hell
no one else can find masks but Apple got
20 million of them hold another question
but they got 20 million of those masks
bring them to the US they're gonna
distribute them I don't really
understand how but they're gonna give
them out to people but now what they're
doing is they're creating face shield so
we ever see a picture of a nurse they
have the masks on right that look kind
of like a normal medical thing and they
got a face shield like a welder but it's
all clear what they're actually
manufacturing not source of but
manufacturing is the face shield see
there's only been teaching her things
but can I say my honest opinion to
super-disappointed about what they look
like like Tim Cook showed one in the
video he did yesterday and it looks just
like a little plastic thing that you or
I could make in our back yard like I was
expecting like super sleek maybe with a
little Apple logo like some light-up
eyeballs or something promoting Apple
this is for agreed right but they're
gonna make a million of them a week
right which is a lot yeah are you making
a million in your backyard I'm not but I
just was I was just shocked as to how
floozies the wrong word but they were
just very basic but I guess that's all
that is actually needed right there's
literally just a piece of classic that
shield your face it's got like a little
strap you can go ahead and you can move
it back and forth so it's pretty cool to
see Apple doing this because it overlays
with a lot of the other companies that
are making ventilators or they're
producing masks etc yeah do you think
that mash mash mash mash mask mask mask
is a mask fashioned gonna be a thing
after this I think so I'm seeing a lot
of really trendy scarves I'm seeing a
lot of like trend
did I see this girl hi what was it it
had like a message on her face mask like
stay the [ __ ] at home would you wear a
mask with your name on it like a cross
okay would you wear one with like a
brand like a Nike check on it
no no but you would wear like a Nike
headband with a Nike check so why not a
mask well maybe if it's not like a
massive look in the corner
okay would you wear one that said like
words across it that wasn't a brand
maybe if I'm feeling like particularly
bold bold would you wear one with like a
I don't know me person like a a Burberry
like a what what those shoes oh yeah all
right so what we'll take a quick joke
real quick a little timeout from lunch
money sometimes you get around the
cooler you don't just eat you actually
have to get some jokes in I actually
know make them guess now I'm just gonna
tell the story so what I'm going to ask
me about a company with the red bottoms
on or whatever and I was like oh yeah I
know the Louis Vuitton shoes that what
you say and I said Louis Vuitton and she
goes what do you know about that my
buddy Louis from Jersey City cuz I
thought it was ello uie and then but Tom
might be a tto n I did rise it was
sparkly different so just in case
anybody's wondering red-bottom shoes or
not Louis Vuitton in Jersey City
it's something else so apples making a
million masks pay they're actually
shields actually happen we have to
fact-check the topics that we sent to
joe because it's not Apple masks it's
Apple shield but go ahead to small
business wait everyone small business
yes well third one
oh he comes after two yeah so so okay so
it looks like a lot of small business
owners are worried they're not the pot
of money that the government has
allocated for small business loans will
run out before the business owners are
able to get any of it yeah there's two
problems here one is it's very unclear
who's eligible for the lungs and who's
not there's about three hundred fifty
billion dollars earmarked in the
stimulus for small businesses and then
not only is it who can get in who can't
but then there's a credible obstacle
actually getting it so if you look at
first of all who's eligible who's not
there's multiple types of stimulus
everything from the payroll protection
program PPP which is not to be confused
with PPE what you guys learned about
last week but PPP is a loan program or
basically you can continue to pay your
payroll if you keep people employed for
a certain period of time that loan will
be forgiven over time the challenge to
that is on Friday those loans opened up
and so people can start to apply for
them but there's two set three separate
groups one is banks say hey come right
in we'll help you apply for these loans
and actually get you the loan that's
great they're doing what they're
supposed to be doing Bank of America
others are in that category there's a
second group that says we are only going
to help clients that meet a certain
threshold so if you've never borrowed
from us before okay you're going to
daily category you basically if you're
not already like a really deep customer
with us you don't get access right but
even though I mean there's examples of
people who have been deep customers with
the bank it's like chocolate yeah yeah
because they never borrowed before so
they may have big bank accounts right
and big deposit amounts but they don't
actually have borrowed before that well
if you think that's bad let me teach you
about the third category which are the
real bad people which are the banks who
literally are just saying this is too
confusing we're not gonna participate so
literally we're not gonna give you and
we're not even gonna help don't even
send us anything
are they well if you're a customer of
the bank and you need a loan aren't they
harming you no I think that it's their
absolute duty to help the small
businesses get the loans whatever you
possibly can do you should go into what
happens if that 350 billion runs out
before some people have had a chance to
even well Stefon gonna run out at some
point right you think they'll print more
they're gonna have to the two trillion
dollar stimulus package I don't think
will ever be enough so they're gonna
have to come up with more right so it'll
be future stimulus packages on top of it
but we'll see how that works but
unfortunately while a small businesses
are having trouble doing this obviously
we saw the unemployment rate skyrocket
last week three point two eight million
two weeks ago six point six million
unemployed this past week it's for a
total of 10 million new claims in the
last two weeks I don't see that slowing
down any time given we're all sitting at
home which leads us to the fourth topic
4 comes after 3 which
mental health what's happening Nick so
you know how you know I've been worried
about people's mental health since the
beginning of this virus that's all point
plena has called this out from day one
well Nostradamus right that's the person
who sees the future
Nostradamus I'm just worried because I
feel like we're already the United
States Ernie is in the middle of like a
loneliness epidemic people are too
lonely
and unlike 9/11 and Katrina and all
these like horrible tragedies we've been
through at least people can come
together and support each other with
this it's such a weird thing because
like you can't even be in the same room
with the people you love so gotta zoom
with him yeah right well yeah but it's
just like humans are social animals and
they need that if we're animals by the
way just going back we should be able to
use the animal test for front of iris
but go ahead okay so I died again so
suicide hotlines across the country are
reporting new increases in the number of
calls they're fielding since the
beginning so basically one of the
concerns here is during economic
downturns there's a very real impact on
life because suicide rates go up alcohol
and drug abuse goes up homelessness goes
up there's all of these components that
get added into it and so if you look at
like here's the numbers that I ran last
week which really scared the [ __ ] out of
me is if you look at the unemployment
numbers and just say 0.1% of the
population end up committing suicide you
very quickly get to 10,000 people out of
the ten million right I think that's
point one percent if I'm wrong you guys
all correctly but 10,000 people
that's more than a diving coronavirus
already now you can't well you can you
know why not because you can't the
coronavirus number will continue to
increase but if the unemployment number
continues to increase raised to
different battles that the u.s. is
fighting right now and it's like you
can't pick and choose one I think you
can undertake of course it's not a black
and white solution because the problem
is not black and white you can't say hey
we have to solve the health crisis and
ignore the economic you also can't say
we're going to solve the economic crisis
and ignore the health there's some kind
of middle ground yeah right so
unfortunately mental health concerns
Nostradamus over here or the female
Steve Jobs with turtle mech has been
dead on in the sense of we're seeing
data points that would suggest that
mental health is deteriorating their
individual data points right now but
obviously something that continued to
pay attention to overtime yeah all right
on a lighter note kwibi this is going to
be hilarious because what are these
people doing go ahead okay so quit me
launched today the company has raised
more than 1.75 billion dollars with no
product on the market nothing they were
just like trust us were well they have a
team the team is very impressive
yeah Jeffrey Katzenberg and I'm Jeffrey
Katzenberg he's a longtime Hollywood
legend do you think isn't the poem like
a coma no okay just wondering while
we're on the Nipplegate I saw a couple
you guys talked about in the comments
Nipplegate just want to make sure in
former eBay and HP CEO Meg Whitman is
this partner so it's a very interesting
Silicon Valley Hollywood like mixtures
yeah okay they're not actually married
I'm just saying and so they created
kwibi kwibi is basically short or
combined words of quick bytes so now
your whole thesis is what to produce
high-quality video content for
Millennials the problem is and I've been
very vocal she was the figure that I am
28 years old I fit right smack in the
middle of their target demographic and I
do not think that I would pay $4.99
without or was it $14.99 with ads and
$7.99 without ads I think that's
accurate double check it fact check for
their content to watch videos on my
phone because I don't watch the Facebook
original content I don't watch the
snapchat original content I don't want
that Instagram whatever original content
so and those are free why on earth would
I pay for this is it just because of the
quality yeah but the whole idea so part
of their argument is this like 10 minute
or less snippets of video that are super
highly produced and it's pretty funny
because some of their
marketing material it's like you can
even hit pause and come back later if
you're like it's something like I don't
know
fact-check fact check the long story
short is it's super short video ten
minutes or less and they wanted to be
episodic in nature and it's gonna be all
original content and it's kind of built
for the whole idea that like everything
that goes on your phone you can sit and
watch it there in short kind of bursts
the problem is I think you and I both
agree on this unlikely to succeed simply
because the original content that's
being produced in other places and other
mediums in traditional format whether
it's Netflix HBO whatever that's
actually some people already and to
raise that kind of money like what kind
of exit are you hoping for
well the venture capitalists are hoping
for at least ten plus billion dollar
exit a few very raise 1.75 billion
that's just get the investor's tax their
money yeah technically 17 billion yeah
like they have these short videos and
they say that Millennials do have really
short attention span so they're gonna do
episodes of ten minutes to watch an
entire movie so entire movie could take
you 17 episodes to watch but my point is
alternatively you could just press pause
on your movie and come back to it later
you don't I don't need you to make these
10 minutes because that's my attention
span I think you just woman explained to
me you said glad I did nice alright but
one thing I will do is I'll play with
devil's advocate right that's a person
on the sex which is master class what
you recently got she's now a master
class customer not on that no ads yet
but call us if you need always be
selling or always be closing ABC closing
but if you flip around the other side
and you're the devil's advocate master
class has five - like eight-minute clips
right and you watch them kind of
episodically and learn from somebody oh
hi
but Jeff call me man if you need help on
the marketing side of guys a lot of
times I'll be in the middle of a ten
minute
episode you know press pause and come
back to know where do you have to go in
the ten minute episode well right now
nowhere because we're all here but
normally if I have important business to
do outside of this apartment I would do
that
polina got mad at me yesterday because I
ate too much food just so you guys all
know I want to get out of the air my
grievances while we can oh my god I
think I'm like a trashcan yeah I think
by the way there's just one rule before
we get into the ones money winner from
Friday there's one rule in our house if
you buy the food and bring it in it's my
responsibility to eat it so if you don't
want to eat don't bring it in the house
also passability shout out to our friend
dustin who said this he said if you
bring something unhealthy in the house I
will eat it ya know it's like a
animalistic like function you have to
eat it like and you don't just eat it
you inhale it as fast as your trying to
do and you're trying to link this back
to the tiger but it's not I'm just here
for you guys with the content on Friday
we said anybody who shared the URL but
the video could get some free lunch
money remember while while she's trying
to get rich the rest of us just trying
to get a lunch money right many of you I
actually was surprised how many people
there is the winner
Dylan Lear who hit us oh wait that's the
that's the payment that's not his actual
tweet his tweet said at a pop that I was
on fire you get points for saying nice
things about me to fire emojis with the
dollar and he said it would behoove
inside jokes for you guys everyone to
subscribe to his channel get your lunch
money right and find out how much plain
Tamara Nova loves Oreo cookies and big
pan I mean come on he had every inside
joke in there he used the hashtag he and
emojis and he shared the URL winner
winner chicken dinner
so we've been mode Dylan yeah we're
Wonder chicken dinner you ever heard
that before because he won he's a winner
right so but rather than lunch when he
got a chicken dinner because they got on
our box
it's okay some of us still are mentally
so when we been with this - Dylan
Dylan's actually stuck right now in
India so happy to help him out he keeps
watching the shows we appreciate that
and we will continue at random episodes
to give out some free
money so keep watching and hopefully
you'll be a winner soon any closing
words miss Steve Jobs do you like that
by the way it's way better than when she
hit us last week with hello you cats
it's not okay I'm gonna end it with this
one last thing the bet the best tweet I
saw yesterday when the Bronx Zoo the
tiger got infected with the corona virus
a cramped capital on Twitter tweet of
the article and he said it was Carole
[ __ ] Baskin and put parentheses Joe
exotic voice I thought I was the best to
beat at all because she she killed her
husband she go Tigers you know allegedly
allegedly she did all right guys listen
we appreciate you guys watching while
while she's trying to get rich the rest
of us just trying to get a lunch money
right every day new nish why is because
we get we don't have our [ __ ] together I
almost did but we don't have our [ __ ]
together
damn may come out before noon afternoon
right at noon or at 5:00 p.m.
shout out to Joe who has helped us
record these per all these nice graphics
off make us look super legit while we
sit in our kitchen with all of our great
tasting food behind us and I have the
beautiful employee Baranova with us go
subscribe to read the profile calm
basically like a walking ad at this
point I can just read real fast alright
guys we'll see you tomorrow
[Music]